[Música]
nunca de maneira a igreja começa em 1981
casai
[Música]
minha família é 50 pra poder cuidar com
essa imagem
o social alguns familiares começaram a
discutir uma posição no mundial é muito
importante
jono certo desgaste no nosso caso nós
foi um desgaste isso com sérias
conseqüências não só patrimoniais mas
também emocionais para todos
se você conhece alguém vazou na internet
é uma série de emoções escassas não só
aumentava as escolhas de cada processo
como também por cada linha
ele começou um movimento simples e
conversava passar o natal
andou com frequência e depois dessa
questão e aí eu trago já há umas abordar
esta como a história do futebol
inteligente e transformar um cenário
aparentemente que fiz com o porto
realmente de translação e essa relação
ainda perguntei o coxa pra minha mãe
como é que uma das minhas tias regional
para chamar a empresas com problemas
papas ativa nesse processo judicial
a sentença foi dada a decisão foi feita
com essa relação
permanecia num espaço em um estado
bastante desconfortável porque o que se
passou
o menino ele é razão de 3 a 5 medicina
veterinária e pra isso ele passa a ter
amor carinho e me perguntava como é que
eu posso realmente as pessoas estão
direito
[Música]
assim o palácio fazer cuidados quando
muitas vezes as pessoas não conseguiram
resolver pelas suas mãos que buscaram
acusam então buscava em com auxílio de
um profissional qualificado por exemplo
e ainda na graduação
eu conheci a mídia só mediação é uma
metodologia de souza a ação nacional e
internacional também a finalidade de
ajudar as pessoas a entender melhor o
que elas querem não só a atuação
mediação e negociação também a formar
pessoas atual com soluções discutir
soluções para a resolução do conflito é
cortar a comunicação confirma a nossa
por isso é normal mas você e eu não te
respondo mais no azar pelo êxito em
encontrar você que o segundo grande
passo logo após cortar a comunicação é
buscar aliados e nesse momento de busca
de aliados e esse é um comportamento
padrão de conflitos ou seja busca a liga
o colega de trabalho
você começa a partilhar o seu ponto de
vista sobre a questão
e agora a gente pode colocar o que
acontece normalmente as pessoas com quem
você interage vai naturalmente reforçar
a sua posição
e aí a gente tem um espaço entre as
pessoas nos disseram que a escolha certa
ela começa a se distanciar reforçadas
pelos alegados pelo corte da comunicação
em nosso cérebro ele é especialista em
reduzir se em algo complicada situações
que nós vamos criar os naturalmente pra
sobreviver porque eu e você somos
guiados pelas orelhas sobreviver às
situações trágicas que ter por aí com
pessoa
a pessoa da nossa bastante delicada
conceber e por mais complicado que seja
o ser humano consegue superar e sair
também para atualizar bom eu e você
somos feitos para sobreviver
essa programação inicial a 0 e depende
de nós somos feitos também que quando a
gente sai o desconforto do conflito nada
mais é do que uma solução teremos boas
soluções naturalmente quando eu e você
podemos promover com a matéria prima
base para construir uma solução
naturalmente essa solução no espaço será
construído em são paulo ela está comigo
é gerar vida porque as pessoas
assassinadas em conflitos geralmente em
reações naturais e aí da medicina na
área de exames como por exemplo uma
descarga da mina descarga com o sol anos
outros elementos que são liberados no
corpo humano que gera resultados
bastante desconfortáveis sociais
algumas questões onde eu passo começa a
minha com a sua abstenção de ver na
verdade eu e você que percebemos um
funcionário e um passo seguinte é é agir
aí vocês a informação logo após a nossa
reação
nós temos um terceiro passo para
resolver a questão
nós como pó resolver bem e quando
precisou dar um passo a passo como estou
me ajuda em nada a situação ganhou em
agir bem eu preciso falar mais de nós
como estou tendo esse cenário que é
perceber a oportunidade
no meu dia a dia de trabalho bem feito
tem que conciliar os estudos eo auxiliar
no entendimento dos looks apercebeu com
um ombro só e eu tenho a percepção que
gera uma reação e essa atitude ela é
terceiro gol também vai escolher
escolher conscientemente não escolheram
olha é impossível
aos 22 minutos além do tempo todo e nós
perceber duas posições à frente de dois
pontos
ameaça acontece chegar como ameaça ou
uma oportunidade que a recompensa
resolver bem estabilizado em estabilizar
[Música]
em ser vocês como presidente
curiosamente a conversa demais sofreram
alguma coisa porque é como se pensa
a gente é responsável e rodar
provavelmente é mais que a gente escuta
aqui
porém ele como o mundo nessa rosato
baixo primeira pessoa é um pouco pra que
nós possamos respirar julgar eu percebo
eu vejo eu sinto bem por dia você vê
você vence a história de justiça
ele é estupro furto de bens situações
vai falar após
pelo que escutei inscrito em um ensaio é
duro ouvir atentamente por nós não temos
pra responder em novos não compreender
das vezes colocar os meios para
responder
nós perdemos bastante tempo bastante
energia
indicando como para o flu respondeu aos
fãs a nossa escuta ao invés de qualidade
então houve aposta para após ouvir
atentamente é um excelente caminho para
que possamos resolver uma inteligente
nós contra eles
escolher conversar e se tornando também
é uma escolha também a opção que fazemos
norte aqui a nossa história
tenho vivido isso a cada dia de julho
pessoas com histórias transformadas
através de um meio mais confortável o
meio de diálogo no meio de uma decisão
colocando as suas histórias através de
escolhas bem coladas nesse sentindo
todos nós fizemos história
qual é a história